ve
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
merak etmekle aramak keşfetmek ve
yaşamak Sanırım benim hayatım Bu dört
kelime içerisinde yerinde tam
bulunmaktadır şöyle başlamak isterim
henüz dört yaşındayken Akşamları tek
özlüyor taş evimize babamın sesi
düşüncelerini merakla dinler yatarken
ben onun gibi kafamda sorular ve
cevaplar ardı
Sabahları erkenden kalkar beni el
arabasını bindirir
bu köy Barajı'ndaki daha sularının
taşıdığı verimli toprağa doldurur
birlikte yaklaşık 10 kilometrelik yolu
gider
ardından arazideki taşlara temizler
verimli toprağı buraya döker dik
onun hayalinden ilk adımınız o attığı
Zorlu süreç başlamış olurdu gece gündüz
demeden pes etmeden çalışıyordu ya sen
deli misin Burası Çorak su gelmez börtü
böcek uğramaz Yani insanlar
babamın hayaline Bizler gibi inanarak
çaba ve emeğe şahit olmuşlardır
O
zamanla nasırlaşan ellerle taşına Toprak
26 döneme yayılmış
dümdüz ve çorak arazide ufak ufak kavak
ağaçları boy göstermişti
bugün ıldırın Karakuyu Köyü ne gidin
Yahya Bey'in çiftliğinin soru
göreceksiniz meyve ağaçları farklı bitki
çeşitleri kuş sesleri bir sürü börtü
böcek ve çevresindeki farklı çiftlikler
beri İşte benim hayatımda o çorap
topraklarla aynı gelişim sürecinden
geçtiğini söyleyebilirim sizlere
doğduğum Karakuyu köyünde ailenin ilk
torunu olarak ilgi konuşma ve yürümeye
başlayana kadar güzeldi Daha doğrusu
çocukluğumu yaşıyordum her çocuk gibi
abone ol
bu sonra beklentiler ve talepler
şikayetçi değildim Aslında Severdim iş
yapmayı iş yaparken büyüklerimi izler
yapabilmek için çalardım yarı Göçebe
kültürü içerisinde gittiğimiz kaç
Yaylası'nda kutuların başına gider
yapılan uyarılara rağmen olmadık yerlere
girer çıkar
çark aldırdım taşların altında börtü
böcek Arar kimi zamanda
parmaklarımı taşların arasına sıkıştırır
acıyla anlamama koşardık İşte o zaman
keşfediyor ve yaşıyordum bu hayatı ama
her zaman Beklediğiniz gibi bir sonuç
Olmuyor yine olmam gereken yerde
istemeden bir köpek havlasın ayranı
olmuştu
bu Hastane odasında kendime geldiğimde
videomu farklı yerlerinden ve yüzünden
ısırılmış tım
bu
yaramazlığın dan Daha doğrusu merakından
hiçbir şey kaybetmemiş olan ben
bu tedavi sonrası köye döndüğümde bu
olay konuşulurken babaannemden habersiz
aldığım kibritle köyün bütün ya toplanan
ekinlerini ateşe verince meraklı bir
çocuk olmanın Yanlış yer ve zamanda bana
getirilerini görmeye başlamıştı
ama
Bizler doğduğumuz hayatta sabit
yaşamaktan ziyade kendimizi güncelliyor
öğrendiklerimizi uygularken başka
yenilikler öğren kazanıp yolumuza devam
ediyoruz
benim öğrenme şeklimizi açıkçası çok da
kabul görmüyordu
köy sakinlerine göre
buyruklarına uymuyor babama bir ceza
olarak doğmuştu
bu çevresinden soyutlanmış beş yaşında
bir çocuk beş yaşında bir çoban ve
kendisine teslim edilmiş koyunları ile
beraber Sakın Aa evin civarında
uzaklaşma Bense de dağ yamacında
gördüğüm için parıltısına koyunlarımı
delalet eder bulacağımız kırık bir şişe
ve cam parçası olsada koyunlarımı taze
Otlar Bana da yeni bir macera olurdu boş
parıltısı
bu meraklı keşfetmeye aç çocuk
çobanlarda Biz sürü lerimizi birleştirir
azdıkları aramızda paylaşırdık bizim
tatlı rekabet lerimiz vardı yakışırdık
sınırları aldırmadan yarıştırdık ve
altında oturduğumuz göğe doğru yükselen
Demir merdivene tırmanmaya başlamıştık
Biraz tırmandıktan sonra gözümün önünde
duran Demir levhadaki kuru kafa resmi
görmüş devam etmiştir bu tırmandıkça
göre yükseliyordu Saki yüksekten
kopsamda en tepeye çıkmak istiyorum
o eve çıkmıştım son basamakta Sağ elimle
teli kavradım da Kut beni zorla kendine
çekmiş
ve bu acısına bağrına basarak
o alevler içerisinde akma bırakmıştı bu
kurtulmak için sol elimi verdiğim değil
en yüksek yerinin dileğiyle çıkmış
elektrik çarpması sonucu beni
kayalıklara doğru fırlatmıştır
16 yaşında bir çocuktum ve bundan sonra
Gerçekten
ağır koşullara gireceğim hayatına ilk
adımlarını adım atmıştı
battaniyeleri hasarı Hastaneye
götürülürken babamın dizlerinde
mutluydum babam ise ağlamamak için
çabalıyordu kollarım yanlış
vücudumda derin Yanıklar ve kırıklar
olmuştu
bu
götürüldüğünü hastaneler çözümü olmamış
bu ve köyü tandırlı yeni hastane mi
olmuştu
bu devam eden tedavi sürecinde Herkes
bir çare ararken biri ise bu kurumuş
parmaklar çürümeye başlayan yaralarında
dolaşan beyaz kurtları yüzüyor çığlıklar
ve Ölümü bekliyordum gözlerde ama o
gözlerini Aksine ben hala aynı çocuktum
ve yeniden ayağa kalk malıydı
bir rüya gördüm Babamı anlattım Bana
inansın umutsuz olmasın diye içimde
durmak bilmeyen Ayağa kalkma isteğiyle
ayağa kalkmaya başlasam iyileşmeye
başlasam da artık ailemin yanında
yaşayacaktım maddi ve manevi çaresizliğe
düşen babam çözümü devletin ilgili
birimin de o
o bulmuş başvurmuş ve kabul olmuştu
koruma ve bakım altına alınacak devletin
çocuğu olacaktı
Bu
annemin yaşlı ve yalvaran gözleriyle
Ildır arkamızda bırakmış bu şu zun ve
Buruk bir yolculuğun aldığından Ankara
Saray çocuk yuvasına ilk adımımızı
attığımızda bir sürü çocuk sesi bizi
karşılamış olsa da o seslerin her
birinde umutsuzluk bir bekleyiş vardı
bir her merdiven basamağında Üstümü
başımı düzeltip gözlerini benden kaçıran
okurca ve sert Adamda
da acı ve yorgunluk vardı gözlerinde
yok bacım okşayarak Sen uslu dur ben
sana bir çikolata alıp geleceğim
dediğini yapmak istesemde içimdeki çocuk
buna izin vermiyordu o boğazında
düğümlenmiş kelime ile arkasından gitmiş
Bir kaç dakika sonra iki koridorlu
birini yanlış tarafına konuşmuştum İşte
o saatte başlamıştı Türkçe bilmeyen 7
yaşında küçük bir çocuk anne ve babasız
Biz kendi yemeğini bile yiyemeyen
fiziksel bir engelli İnanın bana
bedenimdeki ağrılar ve yaralar bunların
yanında hafif kalıyordu
Onu geçen her saniye
beni umutsuzluğa doğru çekiyor karanlık
bir kuyuya doğru itiyordu
E tabii bu bir çözüm değildi o
geçmek bilmeyen birkaç haftanın ardından
merakım yeniden başlamıştı
acaba ailene yapıyordu onlar da beni
özlüyorlar mıydı
işte Benim Köpeğim Ne yapıyordu Şimdi
bensiz sorular sorular ve ben bu
durumdan nasıl kurtulabilirim
bu işte bu soruya cevap verebilecek hale
gelmem yıllarımı alacaktı ve bir yerden
başlamam gerekiyordu ilk başta Türkçeyi
öğrendim
Ardından başkasına nasıl bağımlı
olmayacağını ve nasıl sıradan bir insan
olabileceğini öğrenecektim
Selam bugün düşünürüm ve sorarım kendi
kendime
Ama babam o uzun ve yorucu ve buruk dolu
yolu nasıl geri gitti soranlara ne cevap
verdi
bugün sizlere anlattığım babamın hali
var yani o Çorak Toprak İşte ben o
durumdaydım yaşasam da kimseye yük
olmayacaktım
e Devlet yemeğimi yedirecek Üstümü
başımı giydirecek bazen mutlu edecek
bazen mutsuz yani çok fark etmeyecekti
bu izdenizde
abone ol
ve
merak etmek aramak keşfetmek ve yaşamak
Hani bu dört kelime var ya o
Bir kibrit ucunda dağda bayırda taşın
altında aradığım Bu dört kelime anladım
ki Aslında bu beğendim
Ya aslında kendimi tanımam gerekiyordu
hep uzaklara gider olmadık yerlerde
kendimi aramışım
o o
ben kendimi tanıdıkça inanıyor inandıkça
keşfediyor keşfedildi ettikçe yaşıyordum
şu yaşadıkça ya öğreniyor daha çok
çalışıyordu
abone ol
mi
Evet yapabilirim
ne yapabilirim ve yapıyorum 8 yaşımda
okul sıralarında dişlerimle kalemi tutup
kanalımı yaptığım zaman
öğretmenimin gözlerindeki heyecan İnanın
bana rüyalarıma girmişti işte dedim
Bundan sonra bana acıdık larında
çizgilerine dik duracağım
ne mutlu ki bana inananlar varmış Asla
pes etmeyen inatçı ısrarcı rehberlerim
ve toz toprak demeden yapabilir mi
yapamaz mı oynayabilirmi oynayamaz mı
hayatlarının her aşamasında
yaşamlarını ve Oyunları'nda beni dahil
etmiş arkadaşlarım ve yüz kardeşleri ve
devletin ve milletin sayesinde bugün
lisansüstü eğitim okuyorum hayata
akademik seviyede bakabiliyorum
bu dişlerimle tuttum kalemle resim
çiziyorum portre karakalem
moda tasarım tasarım dijital tasarım
Hatta bu konuma bağladığım fırçayla
kendi evimi kendim boyuyorum
ve Türkiye Cumhuriyeti bayrağını milli
forma adı altında
Avrupa ve dünya Oyunları'nda teslim
temsil ediyor yüzme Kickbox video
Bir de on parmak ayak parmaklarında on
parmak klavye kullanıyorum
bu Photoshop eliuz After efect gibi
programlarla hayatta yeni tasarımlar
kazandırıyor
ölmek gibi olmasın sıradan bir insanım
Sıradan bir insan derken başkalarının
umutsuz bakışlarıyla yargılanmadan
istediği zaman sinemaya gidebilen
seyahat edebilen yemek yapabilen
yırtığında ki yeni dikebilen Sıradan bir
insan başkalarının umutsuz duygusal
kararlarıyla yargılanmadan özgürce
fikirlerini ifade edebilen Sıradan bir
insan
Bu otobüs programına katılacağım zaman
Ne anlatacağım diye sordum Herkes bana
kendini anlat dedi Ben de anlattım
herkesin yazıldığı Hayat kitabında ben
de bir sayfayı daha yazımı Tamamlanmamış
bir sayfa ne mutlu ki bana okunmaya
değer okuyuculara sahibim
Ama bu sahnede yer almak ve sizlerle
buluşmak onurdur şahsım adına
bu ve ve inanın kimse size inanmasa da
inanın ama inanırken de merak eden
arayın araştırın bunun keşfedin ve
yaşayın yaşarken göreceksiniz hayatın
içindeki sürprizleri
B Hayatta hiçbir şey için heveste
başlamayı meraklı olun
o karanlık oğlum kararla başlayın
o rehberler bunun benim ilk rehberim
Annemle babam da sonra çevremdeki Her
şey ve herkes bana rehber Oldu oldu
mutsuzluğun içinde mutluluk arayın ben
mutlu olmayı Rahmetli Kemal Sunal'ın
filmlerinin Duygu bulurdum orada herkes
Güler herkes mutlu olurdu
bu
düşmeyin umutsuzluğun kuyusuna umutlu
olun rahmet Aşık Veysel de benim umudum
o kırık sazı yırtık çağı görmeyen
gözleriyle yazdığım Duru idealist olun
Beni müdahale isterim Tarık Buğra'nın
romanındaki Çolak Salih'ten Mustafa
Kemal Atatürk'ü sabırlı olun Ben sabrı
Mevlana'nın sabır Öyle bir iptir ki sen
kopacak sanırsın o gittikçe güçlenir Sen
bitecek sanırsın o gittikçe çoğalır
sözlerinde bulup ve Sokrates gibi olun
sorgulanmayan Hayat Yaşamaya değmez
dünden bugüne bana emeği olan herkese ve
sizlere dinlediğiniz için Hepinize ayrı
ayrı teşekkür ediyorum